this data just come on Papa seven ok not
everybody welcome to it's funny it'll
give me time ok event of a fire rather
in loudoun see clean the emergency
please the building healthy manner and
the positive 70 point which is located
in my cover fire exit in this room is
incapable prevented side please do not
delay the evacuation by collecting
belongings do not use that if the person
is must not be reentered until the final
gate have indian friend please over this
case the Lord spoke on the abilities and
please note this meat meeting for moving
audio for weeks ok oh jeez Francis we
have apologies we have since ray Banton
web Williams substitute members so
noticed i do we have dire council eases
shores substituting the cancelled ray as
soon this is nice and simple
the castle mountain cousins good news
substituting castle web and cancer skill
substituting the castles in water I
thought you'd better choose wisely boss
dr. Smith ok tell me was it in you yes
going five minutes of the meeting held
on the twenty-ninth September 2016 and a
copy and jump and look through everybody
happy that Asylum has a criminal record
Green breathe declarations of interest
if any should come up with sir that's
not that one also our how you realize
halogen light green white dead weight
training limited governs scooting
measures to see the report from
assistant director of legal services for
approval the delegation of shareholder
responsibilities and reserve matters
schedule that's up to you 30 chairman
years ago mages I'm not the assistant
director of being services but happily
covered
report on her behalf so just just saying
quickly remind members why we're here
today at full council last month members
agreed unanimously i think that the
delegation of shares of the shareholder
responsibility sits with this particular
committee counsel and the purpose
tonight from their decisions to further
delegate down some of those
responsibilities and you'll see which
bits i'm referring to in the appendix
hopefully they're your have which those
responsibilities during the sort of far
right column or won't go through the
wilderness any vendor wishes to cover
anything and so to further delegate
those responsibilities and down from
this committee to the chairman and
vice-chairman of this committee to do
certain things and these are for the
reason of business efficacy so we don't
have to come to this committee every
time we want to make a relatively modest
decision so so to make things fast and
businesslike so that's the reasoning
behind it and the other two elements of
life members to make decisions and ideas
to formally appoint build trimers
chairman of the board of the subsidiary
company for for one year as you'll see
their members and also to amend the
accounting reference date of the again
that the subsidiary trading company
sorry take a company from third person
31st of March so that's essentially it
members and preys on to exciting's like
but it's it's a needed decision we
haven't got you here for the sake of it
something had to formally do before
setting up that before that company
actually still operate next month and as
you have any questions those are the
recommendations as I think I've heard a
couple comments about the on keeping
roast papers before just a correction
which I think I'm capsular mrs. by
submission gas back item 6 item point 3
night and six you've got 30 person I
don't know obviously obviously we should
be third have November yes kind of
everything that then leads onto my main
point is that the company was set up i
did query the 30 of the november through
the chair and i was told that the 30th
november was the best date to have the
year end because it meant the lirc
workload within the castle itself was
less at that point if we if we had a
31st a large year-end for this company
it mendon the officers who were doing
the council also be doing the council's
accounts and their complete problems and
that's why the thirst in no event was
felt to be the best date was that would
be a quiet period k confirm them what
has changed in that respect and are we
confident the one mean with this year in
date that will be engaging outside help
with the accounts yes i can answer
chairman
you are correct counselor there was the
original thinking from the finance
department to separate out the dates a
so we can up you know allocate the
workload in a portion of a different
sites however it's in stratified that
the same finance office is a as the as a
thing to develop to actually come back
and said no we prefer it to be on on the
same date to make it easier for them so
they've actually made that request so so
we have that from that pet Liam Rob Rob
Manning so that that's the reason behind
I figured and the only other point was
in the dedicated to tease yeah towards
the bottom item 30 oh sorry item 39 the
changing the financial year the company
can be any person dedicated student with
dedication authority from the investment
board but things we try to consider
myself to be a sapper to be similar such
as that change the name of change the
Richard office required you'll throw out
the decision to be a muppet made by the
Philly investment bald can you explain
why the why they different to me that
they're both administrative within the
company and they don't get to me they're
not different in that respect I wonder
why they look different because it's
exactly that could be quite as trading
year into the tumbling well I mean the
simple answer chairman is is that this
is the this is the template as a college
guy are experts sort of the city lawyers
Weaver human prophecy paying for and
this is this is what they produce
than what they've seen in action before
and the best template as it were
obviously it's not set in stone we were
to decide that actually there was a
better arrangement for whatever reason
that we can change that but as it stands
though it was deemed to be the best
setup in terms of business advocacy
having having that having this
arrangement in place and it's a balance
of power basically who does what and
what what what other the big decision
block sit with full council the sort of
second biggest city of yourselves as a
whole committee and then lastly you know
other decisions sit sit with the
chairman advice check if your remaining
to delegate that down tonight and just
for clarification on rytan 2.4 we are
shortening the year-end so the first
year will end on 31st not 2017 exactly
so it'll be a four-month year sort or a
four-month set four pounds will be
prepared I'm not sure doing so you'll
probably understand this for them myself
counselor what a legal what if you ought
expect you to be the 31st along well
that's probably the correct answer then
bogeyed affirmative they did one other
point chairman is that this is something
you you sell chairman picked up last
time it may not be reflected in here
whatever reason better full council you
raised the point on page six point five
this is appendix at last the last
the last row 18 listen to create or
agree a charge of security of the
council agreed the words to be added
following advice of the section 151
officer that should appear in there
we'll have that change but that one
wasn't admitted on purpose it was just
an admission of thing so where that
place back in chosen one yeah just to
clarify something on appointment
counselor always raised I think this in
the column that this is in the one that
you're referring to 29 presumably this
committee will have any danger authority
to somebody to check that day right even
there is nobody at this time well if if
tonight in the members / binding to
delegate to the chair and vice chairman
there that'd be one of their future and
powers lotensin to do that not sleepy
though both of them so you'll be
delegating those kinds of decisions to
them all those ones in the third column
will sit with you but the point I wanted
to make my main through kalyan is that
I'm not being funny about this but there
is a right of calling as you know for
decisions now the whole point of this is
to make quick decisions and get things
through now if all decisions may know
this committee subject to the right of
cortland by review do something Sonia
may be answering only problem with that
is that where we want that you know can
you I know that there are certain
decisions that we can make them we say
sorry because of the decision type of
decision there's no right of pulling can
we still do that with some of the
decisions because it may well be
decisions but we don't necessarily want
to write a call it if the space would
have to take her again this is the idea
of this committee and beat
representative exactly to say counselor
cup Morris is his business efficacy than
the speed so we'll always have to have
that in mind but still having that you
know this is still is a committee and it
was still taking the subject according
as you say about people just have that
habit at the forefront of our mind that
we were doing these things you know if
we are to delay decisions you know
hopefully that be doesn't that in the
rarity hopefully a good reason it made
it have implications on the business in
that it can't buy ASAP machinery or I
can't do something Bridget it may affect
rain which announcement affects the
council in terms of its its return and
business investment okay but just just
to clarify the point I was making is I
know that they can be decisions made
where we preclude the rise or fall in
don't remember to leave their those at
full council does this committee have
the right to do the same thing in the
right circumstances I'm sure I so do you
have any comments on that I I would
imagine in the same way that term
individual member decisions can you know
can't come you made in terms of urgency
and I see no reason why the committee
could not have either report
brought forward which which are
obviously publicly available to me to
all members of the council and which
should make it clear that the decisions
have to be made to it as a matter of
urgency I think we'd have to have to
look very carefully in the world of
those you know those resolutions very
equity to consider thank you for that I
mean you understand why I'm asking the
question specifically something that you
know is on the cusp of it so as to speak
I have a number of people in cake
because we suppose I did you eat
defective oh I indicated another point
that that was being covered okay okay my
baby yeah it was nice yeah they go out
Terry Terry makes castor cotton what
makes a very appropriate point I think
that's been acknowledged by everyone i'm
not sure like i agreed with them really
officer I don't think there is provision
in our constitution for a committee to
be able to take the discretion of saying
that it's an urgent decision which can't
be called in that's not going to be much
of a problem because the Constitution is
currently under review by the review
committee under the direction of other
illegal officer and I would recommend
that the board asks that to the included
in the review and put subdivision to be
made for the future which it then
doesn't become ambivalence in any way
and I suggest chairman through you that
we help them if members are
uncomfortable you know in terms of the
year their delegations committee chose
the terms of reference as they currently
stand we have a full council meeting
coming up you know sort of raid we can
actually address those the terms of
reference to actually be able to make
the decision smaller more awesome
flexibly thank you dead or 1pm my
question or seeking to find a little bit
further information obviously this this
company will ultimately be coming back
so you provide information to this
committee about its activities on any
relevance and they're really also
potentially be answerable to the review
committee as well and he's there he's
there going to say no likely to be a
different aspect to what reviews likely
to be look let and walk what this this
this committee is going to be doing or
are they likely to be doing the same
sort of job really well I mean though
the way the way we see it and this could
be subject to change depending on with
them so happy buddy cistus is to split
the
the oversight into some three areas if
you like so you have the financial
oversight which I would say is this
particular committee and you are the
shareholders or share our
representatives and then your main
interest the main one there are others
but is is on the the finances of the
company you know where they've got
healthy balance sheet that the accounts
have been submitted at the right time in
the right order and all the rest of it
and the company's in profit and it's you
know legally compliant so those are the
sorts of reports that would come to this
committee and the others of the others
are sort of scrutiny will be with
portfolio holder and the the assistant
director in terms of overseeing the
operations of things a contract is it is
it performing in service you know as per
the contract on time you know to the
appropriate standards and obviously
generalizing me and and then then you
have the sort of general oversight which
which can be you know from the provided
to the review committee by the vinner or
the review committee could decide to
look at specific aspects he's got this
got free rein essentially to do what he
wants to look at y-12 plus is lots of
animation
those are the three areas of it it's in
to avoid duplication in a kind of
reporting industry things we want the
company to be to be doing its job rather
than creating spending most of its time
creating reports you need to get that
balance right so if we split the areas
up the responsibilities of oversight up
in that way that would manage things a
bit better i think and avoid duplication
and time being spectre-4 in this
commercial environment you want the
company to be doing making money and not
churning out lots of lots of paper
impossible but hopefully as time goes by
confidence builds in the company then we
will gather from getting the right i
suspend EFA affection I think this
hearing what nicca said it had the last
black comedian we suggested that
initially aforementioned dissing in
other meetings that somehow we would be
pull the operational whether you need to
finance in the first month but we can
recall the operational it wouldn't take
too long because in theory there
shouldn't be that much going on for the
first couple of months but perhaps on a
monthly basis for the first three months
we would give either written report or
we've come along an outsider myself the
ID both of us or when the director of
Adam Aldridge who would be when we could
give a report to whoever wants a report
on how the first months gone perhaps
after three months we can review what we
need to know what you need to know and
then we could go perhaps by month beam
for a period and then go quarterly I
mean we're all learning on this this
scenario mean from our point of view of
the ID okay I tried to order to myself
we're confident that we were this will
work but okay we understand that you
will want to know vo isn't working and I
think we need a bit of guidance from you
work why have you come and tell you what
going in Eagle hiccups or the very
essence is that we're going to be on it
all day every day effectively we don't
want it to fail but you know we might
not have a lot to report but three
months because if theory there's not
going to be a lot of the routine stuff
that we we will be doing will be no I
mean we'll be getting ourselves
organized ready for the start of the
spring but there will be obviously will
be other bits and pieces doin in the
run-up to it so they say whether you
want to have a delegated group to meet
with another dedicated group I only that
to you chairman we should nice did you
okay yeah we weren't sure you're my vice
chairman wasn't content not work Thank
You mr. chairman I think we have an
issue here that we need to deal with
very carefully the review committee was
used to be called nothing he s why was
it better actually the overview of
scrutiny committed and it's there to
protect in question activities roaming
now to my knowledge and I've jumping on
the review for very long but I don't
think it's often that anything is called
called in ask and I'll comp recall
anything to let my know that has called
the delay so I don't think that's a
problem I think we ought to be very
careful not to take that safeguarding
away and I would endorse counselor mr.
Mason's view that this should be looked
at very carefully in cooperated with the
review of the Constitution because we
are going to have
with the Constitution anyway at the
aspects of the trading company because
none of that's in there so that that
whole that aspect needs to be looked at
I think that lease be incorporated but I
don't think we've been doing away with
it scrutiny should it be needed I mean
if the council fires it's a problem then
it can deal with it but I'd like no
knowledge of any problems caused or
delays caused by an examination so far
of the activities that counselor in fact
I think you Frank guarding for the
council okay everybody else Catholics
are heading to your body miss week its
own because that he's come back on
though cuz always pushing the arsenic
combined Nick at the audit training at
the beginning of the year I'm a junior
what it asks a question about scrutiny
of them Jim's company on our target it
also came under the under the orbit
which is well for certain parts of it so
there are the review committee own which
you can look at it both also be very
wary because he's a very small business
and we don't know to get the directors
so busy reporting to us that they don't
have talked to their work as well and so
does if you're wondering all mine but
I'm not quite sure what they did report
exactly that's why they may very hard it
might be a bit of fun for it'll be used
to be yeah there are various rooms where
even they don't have there are if there
are concerns I think there are number of
sidebar projects throughout the day
fairer system and as has experienced it
you know we're all learning from this
see how that all starts to play an elf
ok any other questions ok well going on
soup and ice boxes on a 6.2 ok there's a
bowl yep can do this ok close these
results the sheriff of representative
roles in relation to Green Bay Point
trading limited and greenway the private
beta waves or trading GN limited be
delegated to the chair and vice-chair on
the investment all subjects and that's
containing reserved matters of the
shareholder agreement right into that
don't try before we pointed his chair
the board of directors for green take
weight training GA Trinity for period of
one year and three the accountant
reference date of a green gateway
trading anonymity be coming from
searches in November to the 31st / March
is everybody happy with that gradient
gradient thank you very much a day
members
[Music]
[Music]
is it for fun